This video is sponsored by Raycon.
Get 15% off their already affordable wireless
earbuds with the link in the description.
February 29th, 2020.
The day of the first Coronavirus death in
the United States, reported at the time.
The day, for Americans, that this mysterious,
highly-infectious disease went from distant
news story to actual, alarming reality.
From the date of that first reported death,
it would take less than one month for the
U.S. to become the most infected country in
the world - passing Italy, then China, and
eventually ending up in a category of its
own.
But although the outbreak was real everywhere,
it was felt viscerally in the northeast, one
of only a handful of places in the country
where headlines of despair seemed to match
the daily experience of locals.
There were not only two waves, but, effectively,
two, distinct, pandemics.
For those in and around New York, the Coronavirus
was all-too-horrifyingly real, creating a
more vigilant atmosphere even now as new local
cases stabilize.
Masks are widely worn, hands, frequently washed,
and public spaces, treated with caution.
Outside of the northeast corridor, a very
different pandemic played out.
One where the first casualties were jobs,
classes, and the conveniences of modern life.
Reactions to government-imposed restrictions
were so geographically divided in part because
the Coronavirus was so geographically divided.
Now, as infections surge across the country,
a once regional crisis is becoming a shared
disaster.
Everyone, everywhere is, in some way, affected
by the virus.
But it would be a mistake to say that everyone
is affected equally.
Just as in the early days of the pandemic,
there are, broadly speaking, two very different
groups of people: Those who’ve lost work,
school, and their livelihoods, and those who
can treat lockdown as a vacation.
Generally speaking, this is an exceptionally
great time to be rich, and an exceptionally
bad time to be poor.
Since March, around 50 million people have
filed for unemployment, setting records not
seen since the Great Depression.
Meanwhile, the country’s richest have seen
their wealth explode.
During that same period, the net worth of
U.S. billionaires has grown by almost 20%,
and a dozen, in particular, have doubled their
wealth.
When most Americans were stuck in their hometowns,
if not their living rooms, the richest among
us, now untethered geographically by work,
school, and friends, were on the move - to
their vacation homes in Jackson Hole, Nantucket,
and Sun Valley.
There, in these small, remote towns, wealthy
families brought from their big cities the
risk of infection.
Teton County, for example, of which Jackson
Hole is apart of, is one of the richest counties
in the country - home, at least during ski
season, of Bill Gates, Kanye West, Christy
Walton, and Dick Cheney, to name just a few.
Its one and only hospital, equipped with just
24 ventilators, was put to the test as private
jets swarmed local airports.
Despite being home to just 23,000 full-time
residents, Teton was Wyoming’s second-hardest-hit
county in April, surpassing other areas three
or four times more populous, until the second
wave hit.
Other wealthy families booked-out entire hotels
or resorts for 20, 30, or $40,000 a week.
Finally, some went even further - preferring
to leave the country altogether.
Private jet companies were inundated with
requests, both from a lack of available scheduled
flights, and a concern for health and safety.
One study suggests regular passenger air travel
involves 270 person-to-person interactions,
while private flights expose a customer to
less than 20.
But while demand for a safe place to hide
is clearly very high, it’s far harder to
find supply.
Pandemic tourists, as you might call them,
are looking for three things:
Someplace Coronavirus is under control,
Somewhere that is isolated and likely to avoid
further outbreaks,
And, of course, somewhere that will let them
in.
The trouble is that any country which meets
the first two criteria likely did so by avoiding
the third.
In other words, any place where outbreaks
are contained likely closed its borders early,
and is unwilling to undo its hard work now.
This rules out the vast majority of countries.
Italy, for instance, denied entry to five
U.S. citizens who flew from Colorado earlier
this month on a private jet.
The risk of allowing them in, despite their
riches, is just too high.
But not everywhere.
There are a few countries where the benefits
of tourism are so, insanely high as to outweigh
the risk of further outbreaks.
These are mostly small island nations like
Fiji, The Bahamas, and The Maldives.
For the latter country, travel and tourism
comprise nearly 40% of its GDP.
These are places that can’t afford to lose
visitors.
But with limited healthcare infrastructure,
they really can’t afford an outbreak, and
therefore had to take the lesser of two very
bad evils.
Take the case of Fiji.
Its borders were first closed on February
3rd, weeks before the first confirmed case,
to any foreigner who had visited mainland
China in the past 14 days, in addition to
screening the health of passengers during
their flights to Fiji.
On the 27th, this ban was extended to all
travelers from Italy, Iran, and parts of South
Korea.
18 days later, cruise ship stops, international
events, and government travel were also canceled.
Three days after that, Fiji confirmed its
first case: a Fiji Airways flight attendant
who had recently flown to San Francisco and
Auckland.
After this first person began a chain community
transmission, infecting four others, locals
expected the worst.
In early March, it became the first Pacific
island country to open a WHO-certified testing
lab, and the fourth Pacific country capable
of testing for COVID-19.
This enabled instant results, rather than
waiting for samples to be sent to Australia.
By the end of the month, its main international
airport was closed and a military-enforced
curfew announced from 10 pm to 5 am.
Then, an amazing 78 days went by between its
eighteenth and nineteenth cases.
As of early July 2020, despite a population
of 883,000 spread across 300 islands, Fiji
has recorded a total of 21 infections, making
it possible to list every past and present
case in a single frame.
It’s also managed a 100% recovery rate,
with the vast majority of recent cases coming
from returning locals staying in quarantine.
In this way, Fiji perfectly encapsulates the
dilemma of countries like it: Having made
early and painful sacrifices to prevent an
outbreak, they now have a new kind of vacation
amenity: being free of Coronavirus, that they’re
eager to reap the benefits from, but at the
risk of making things much, much worse.
Every country, island, and city depends on
tourism to a different degree, and thus, every
country, island, and city has responded differently:
Cuba, for example, has divided the country
such that visitors stay only in designated
resort areas and don’t infect the general
population.
Hawaii, on the other hand, will allow travelers
to skip its mandatory two-week quarantine
if they present a negative test result 72
hours before arrival.
Fiji, like several other countries, has come
to a different conclusion:
It knows that the risk of welcoming visitors
is directly proportional to the number who
arrive, but the number of visitors is not
necessarily proportional to the benefits they
bring.
They can minimize the risk of reopening while
maximizing the income they generate by inviting
only the rich.
To quantify this fact, Australia is the largest
source of arrivals in Fiji, accounting for
just under half of the total.
They spend, on average, $116 US Dollars per
person, per day and $1,039 per trip.
A cruise ship passenger, in comparison, spends
$44 on average per port of call.
And finally, someone arriving by yacht spends
$3,615 during their average stay.
In total, the yachting industry contributes
approximately 28 million dollars to the Fijian
economy every year, not that far behind the
44 million brought by the cruise industry.
Cruise ships expose the islands to 239,000
passengers a year, while yachts expose them
to just 4,473.
By comparing these numbers, we can very crudely
estimate that yachts bring approximately 2%
the risk of infection that cruise ships do,
while contributing 63% as much to the local
economy.
This is the thinking behind Fiji’s new ‘Blue
Lanes’ program, which allows billionaires
to bypass its Coronavirus border restrictions.
Its prime minister announced that yachts and
pleasure craft will now be allowed to enter
one of its ports.
If a ship’s journey there took 14 days or
longer at sea and its passengers show proof
of a negative test result, everyone on board
will be screened for symptoms, and, if deemed
healthy enough, allowed to roam the country.
If their journey was shorter, they can make
up the remaining time in quarantine.
If someone arrives from Sydney after 8 days
at sea, for example, they can pay for six
days of quarantine, and then proceed to hide
out on a remote private island.
And Fiji is not alone, many countries are
competing for the VIP-crowd.
Seychelles is also allowing visitors who arrive
on private or chartered flights and then stay
on an isolated island resort.
Thailand, the Maldives, and other countries
have similar plans.
In all likelihood, only a very small number
of billionaires will arrive - so far Fiji
has announced 30, but that, is precisely the
goal - to cash-in on their strong early pandemic
response, while inviting very little additional
danger.
If it works, international travel may slowly
revert to the status it once held decades
ago: reserved mostly for the rich, and fairly
inaccessible to everyone else.
One thing that is getting much more affordable
are wireless earbuds.
Raycon sent me a pair of their Everyday model
and I’ve been wearing them every week at
the gym since.
They start at just about half the price of
other wireless earbuds, help block out the
noise around you, and last up to six hours
on a charge.
I’ve used other wireless earbuds before
and was pleasantly surprised by how durable
Raycons are.
Although not exactly recommended, I’ve even
heard of them surviving accidental trips to
the washing machine.
They won’t fall out of your ears because
they come with 5 extra different-sized tips,
plus you can even choose from a selection
of six colors to truly make them your own.
Get 15% off with the link in the description
and my thanks to Raycon for sponsoring this
video.